hi good evening and welcome to 57th
Street books
my name is Solva I'm the events
coordinator at the seminary co-op
bookstores this event is one in a series
of reading some lectures that we hold
here at the University of Chicago at the
Newberry Library in various other
locations around the city briefly I
wanted to say that we have our events
mailer out for June and July and we're
trying to get people to sign up for the
internet email flyer to save mail costs
so if you do have an email address and
would like to find out about events that
way we have a purple sheet that you
could sign up on after the talk I'm very
happy to introduce Kenneth Meeks tonight
he's the author of the new work driving
while black what to do if you are the
victim of racial profiling mr. Meeks is
a managing editor at Black Enterprise
magazine he has been a journalist for
many years and has worked for Black
elegance magazine Bell magazine and the
New York Amsterdam news among other
publications well there has been some
media coverage and debate around the
subject of racial profiling and the
related issue of police brutality
there's been little information about
the history of profiling and actual
statistics of its occurrence as well as
importantly what to do if you experience
mistreatment on the basis of your race
or on your general appearance driving
while black fills this gap in an
accessible and even-handed manner this
work addresses a wide range of
situations and provides crucial
information that I think all Americans
should be aware of please welcome mr.
Kenneth Meeks
thank you
good evening everyone thank you all for
coming out I really appreciate it thank
you thank you thank you I want to thank
the 57th Street bookstore for inviting
me
having c-span for coming out and I guess
documenting everything I'm just thank
you all there's on as we all know racial
profiling is a serious problem there's a
story that I tell of a young man from
Atlanta who took a position as a vice
president for PepsiCo in Maryland and
he's from Georgia so his driver's
license was issued from Georgia but when
he moved into a rich rich white
neighborhood in Maryland he bought her a
car when that it was issued Maryland
license plates so you have to understand
him he's a large black man go gate gar
garrison nature and giving and spirit
he's a black man in a suit and a tie
driving a nice car in the first six
months that he lived in his new
neighborhood he had been racially
profiled 18 times and they were all like
within a stone's throw of his house so
finally after the 18th time he finally
just got fed up with it to the point
where he drove to his company picked up
seven cases of Pepsi drove it to the UH
to the police department I got it out
dropped it over in the counter of the
police department and said listen my
name is so-and-so I live in this
neighborhood so-and-so
please leave me alone well ironically
enough that was the last time that he
was over profiled in his neighborhood
sometimes we just have to do things like
that and I won't ever I can't say that
he's never been profiled again but you
know unfortunately he has and he has
plenty of stories to tell the problem
and I guess that's the problem with
racial profiling in general and that too
many innocent people are getting
being victimized by it it's it's
something that you know I'm sure we all
have stories to tell it's one of those
things where young you know where
college professors you know in a suit
and tie know driving a nice car
they did not doing anything wrong but
you know they go into the wrong
neighborhood or neighborhood they
proceed not to to belong in and they're
stopped and harassed for being black
there's another story that that I heard
of a motorist who owns a car and he has
this electronic messenger posted in the
back of his window so that anytime his
cars pulled over he turns it on and in
the back flashes these bright red lights
you know
hi I am pulling over I do not have drugs
I don't own a gun so please don't shoot
me as um as crazy as it sounds I'm sorry
that it's gotten to that point though
when it comes to racial profiling I'm
thinking of actually buying one myself
and I don't own the car never owned one
people ask me why I wrote driving while
black and if I've ever been profiled yes
I've been profound of lots of times for
the last 10 years I had dreadlocks so
that should tell you in itself the type
of stereotypes that have gone on with me
but um I wrote driving while black
basically to save lives it's one of
those things where we need to save lives
empower ourselves so that when we are
racially profiled we know how to
recognize it fight back and pretty much
change the system you know the one good
thing about our court system is that
it's it's one of those things where
individuals can make an impact and
change the legal standing of particular
laws and so I think that when it comes
to law enforcement officers we have to
hold officers accountable for if they're
you know we have to to initiate lawsuits
so that we can put on the books listen
it is illegal to stop a car for because
the motorist is black or Hispanic or
whatever which you know well let me just
stay with with the the thing with law
enforcement officers that they're
killing our kids and we have to do
something about it
that's that's when I say I won't say
driving while black to save lives it's
basically to save the lives of our kids
when my editor Broadway books and I
discussed the idea for this book driving
while black what to do when you're
racially profiled I couldn't help but
remember the story that an article that
I wrote for the New York Amsterdam news
it was on one Christmas morning about
two years ago there was a guy police
officers from the 63rd precinct the mob
from three different precincts in New
York and Brooklyn were responding to
calls that shots had been fired from one
of the rooftops of a nearby building and
this young I know I'm twenty-two year
old black man this Christmas morning
went to a corner pay phone to call his
fiancee Alice fiance to make
arrangements for her their two-year-old
that 11 month old son and her fiance his
two older children to come to the house
for Christmas dinner
well when the when police cars converged
on the corner he himself got nervous
nervous enough that he ducked into a
nearby corner store fine well police
officers according to the New York City
Police Office Department police officers
followed him pursued him into the
storefront and claimed that he appeared
to be hiding in the back room in the
corner and when he suddenly appeared
with something in his hand they shot him
they feared for him they thought that he
had a weapon it turned out that all he
had was a set of keys and a blue hat I
would say he was killed for no reason
that Christmas morning
his story came like a good solid year
before Amadou Diallo was shot 41 times
in the Bronx when I think why I wrote
driving while black it's for stories
like that it's because our innocent kids
are being killed by law enforcement
officers and I think that we have to
take proactive steps to make sure that
it doesn't happen to ourselves our sons
our brothers our fathers our sisters
just people in general because it
happens it happens too much you know as
Chris Rock once said somebody gives a
cop probable cause just for coming out
of the house
so I think that one of the things that
we have to consider when when we talk
about law enforcement officers and the
fact that they're killing our kids and
getting away with it because to date to
date in the history of law enforcement
officers and law enforcement in this
country past two three hundred years
there has only been one police officer
one white officer who has ever tried
convicted and sentenced for killing an
unarmed black man in the history of this
country and that came about a month ago
when he was convicted for killing a
young black man named Franklin Reed and
sentenced to six years but to show you
how powerful the police union is he is
out on bail pending the appeals process
so again they're killing our kids
they're getting away with it and they're
saying that it's our fault they're
saying well he reached for something or
I thought my life was in danger so
that's why I shot unfortunately this one
instance in Connecticut a jury disagreed
with them and saw that he had indeed
racially profiled his victim they had no
reason to stop him in the first place
look you know local newspapers and
national magazines of for statistics
when it comes to who's being killed by
police officers and once again I'm not
trying to indict all along
when officers I think that it would be
unfair for me to do that I believe that
in general law enforcement officers do a
good job most of them are professionals
most of them do practice upholding the
law in a respectful manner
unfortunately it's that small minority
of people a small minority of police
officers that are giving everyone a bad
name and it is de who I believe that we
have to fight against you know so once
it you know as I say racial profiling
and and again racial profiling isn't
just about law enforcement officers it
happens in department stores it happens
in shopping malls it happens and the
elevators it happens
God it happens everywhere you know when
you take a $300
you know if say you you have a purchase
you want to go pay for a credit card you
know you go up to the counter and you
you're you know the lady ahead of you
goes she pays with a credit card all she
does aside her our invoice and she's out
well with us you know it's you show them
the credit card and they want your
driver's license they want a bank
account number they want your birth
certificate they want proof that you
have a job they want this they want that
that's racial profiling so again I have
to remind people that racial profiling
is beyond just state troopers and
minority drivers it really is it it is
it just expands beyond that it reaches
all levels of society so and just
walking through customs I would be
remiss if I didn't mention that coming
through customs
black women in general 20 times more
likely to be searched than a white woman
so just keep that in mind if you're
traveling this this year however you
know things are getting better as we're
talking about racial profiling I believe
just just about a month ago in Federal's
of pills Court recently ruled that u.s.
Border Patrol's can no longer use
Hispanic factors or Hispanic appearance
as a factor for deciding to stop
Hispanic drivers along the us-mexican
border to show you to give you an idea
what I'm talking about
up until a month ago u.s. Border
Patrol's can literally stop Hispanic
drivers driving along the borders only
because there has bonded drivers that's
where it's you're profiling the Supreme
Court upheld that they said it's fine
it's okay to do that it's only after
we've had this dialogue after we've been
talking about it as a nation that they
decided you know I think we need to
revisit that decision other things other
improvements that have that are taking
place as a result of us talking about
racial profiling along our highways last
year I'd say about ten say ten police
departments actually kept track of the
motorists that they were stopping
whether or not they would like whether
or not there were women what sex they
were whether or not the car was searched
and if anything was found in not only
ten agencies around the country today
again because of the dialogue that were
happening with racial profiling today
more than 200 departments are now
keeping track of those such statistics
four states have actually passed laws
requiring that state troopers to keep
track they are Connecticut North
Carolina Washington State and and
Missouri of those that are volunteering
we have cities like Milwaukee Florida
Richmond San Diego Michigan etc and a
whole host of other agencies I should
probably ask that next week Michigan
State will be releasing their findings
on the race on the traffic stop
statistics so I invite you to kind of
keep your here to the new to the just
keep your ear in the wind to see what
type of results they have discovered as
a result of keeping track of who's being
stopped one of the things that we don't
want to happen is what happened in San
Francisco a body
summer where the mayor had actually
asked the police commissioner to keep
track of these statistics to see of
racial profiling was going on for a
whole year they've asked you know and
that's that's a good amount of time I
think to to uh to determine whether or
not racial profiling exists well
unfortunately the police commissioner
decided that they would only keep track
for two weeks rather not on racial
profiling existed and in those two weeks
they concluded that racial profiling
doesn't exist in that city that's the
one thing we do not want to happen among
people who are volunteering to keep
track because they have no mandate we
have we are at their good mercy to keep
track and you know to keep track for to
give it an honest not just an honor
study so we have to take proactive steps
and things like that one of the things
as I've always said I can't possibly
write everything there is to know about
racial profiling that encyclopedia I
can't possibly keep track of every
experience of racial profiling as it
happens in any particular part of the
country or the world for that matter
racial profiling is bigger than me is
bigger than this book is bigger than any
one organization it's gonna take the
collective whole it's like eating an
elephant we have to do a one step one
bite at a time and everyone has to get
involved I think that the best the
driving while black can offer is merely
a snapshot of how racial profiling
exists today it's a how other people it
shows how other people have been
victimized how they have taken proactive
steps to file complaints to to to take
charge of what has happened to them and
to literally try to change the system I
mean it's one of those things where we
have to be our brother's keeper if we're
profile today they're gonna profile our
children tomorrow so we have to do
something today to stop it and part of
it is complaining when it happens
initiating grievances writing letters
you know maybe doing a word of
campaign saying that this store profiled
me this particular Police Department is
really slowly profiling that person is
profiling holding people accountable so
that they would think twice the next
time before they profile again so I
think that I think that one of the
things that I've discovered in this
process was everybody I used to say that
everybody has a story to tell abrasion
profiling well not anymore
it really is getting beyond that it's
important that and even though that's
that's just like one segment of racial
profiling there's another part for any
of us who have children I invite parents
that it's it's really important that we
teach our children how to behave when
we're stopped by police officers I think
that we have to be cognizant about
behaviors when we stop today when police
officers shoot unarmed people they're
blaming us they're saying that we you
know that it's our fault that that we
reached for something so we can't you
know we have to stop doing we have to
just be cognizant of our presence and
put in the police presence I think as as
I'm not you know one of the things that
I say that in the same breath that we
tell our kids to say no to drugs to to
practice safe sex we just we have to
tell our kids how to behave when we are
victims of racial profiling
this is dangerous times for us one of
the things that we need to tell our kids
is to stay calm stay relaxed don't don't
start you know I'm going to sue you
because the way you're talking to me you
know don't react to other people's harsh
behaviors or don't let other people's
bigotry and bad judgment basically get
our kids killed I think that when we are
stopped we have to learn to de-escalate
the situation or the police presence we
have to take note of the time you know
where we are
take note of the police officer in front
of us pay attention listen and never
ever
ever reach for anything you know
whenever when we start reaching for
things that's when that's when they get
to us I think that it's important that
we all understand the difference between
when we are stopped in a cotton we're
stopped as motorists and the police
officers wants to search our cars it's
important that we know the difference
between probable cause and reasonable
suspicion we have to understand that if
an officer has reasonable suspicion oh I
think this guy has drugs he might I'm
not sure maybe hmm I want to search a
car you have the right to say no I like
to exercise my right and not be searched
because there's only reasonable
suspicion if that's the case he has to
ask you to sign over a consent to search
exercise your right and say no you can
do that however if you have probable
cause that the officer has probable
cause and that is you know he sees the
crack pipe in the in the passenger seat
or you know the gun you know in the
backseat that's probable cause if he
asks her to search your car you pretty
much have no choice but but to let him
do that
and it's those type of things that we
need to teach our kids to because they
don't know that as soon as they get a
driver's license let them know you know
that that they have rights as a motorist
because there's so many times when I you
know so many times when my wife and I
are driving down the highway in a rental
car of course I don't own a car but
we'll start you know we're see a police
officer stop you know a car and we'll
notice that the motorist is is black and
we'll see them you know stupid in in the
car and you know how going through the
trunk and all that something I I always
want to stop and say listen did he have
reasonable suspicion did he have
probable cause you have their right to
say no chances are they don't know that
you know we have again we have to be our
brother's keeper sometimes you know this
lady asked you know when I see things
like that you know I always want to stop
and monitor you know make sure that
everything's going all right is that a
good thing to do well yeah sometimes we
should do things like that sometimes we
do need to
be aware and watch the police officers
and make sure that they are not
brutalizing are kids there are some you
know the things that that are taking
place as a result of this national
debate that I think is good that we all
should be aware of one of the things
that the New Jersey State Attorney
General's Office John farmer he joined
me on a radio talk show one day in
Philadelphia and said that his state was
going through serious reforms regarding
racial profiling they have course
entered into a consent decree with the
Department of Justice and promised to
stop using race as a factor for racial
profiling that was the first step by the
end of this year the promises that every
squad car will have videotaping that's
another stuff you know perhaps we should
advocate that among our horn local
elected officials that each squad car
has a video camera so that we know
there's no more anecdotal stories of
people being racially profiled there's
hardcore video coverage and he's
planning on disclosed closing that
information later on in the year we have
to do things like that and we have again
we have to take proactive steps with
regards to eradicating racial profiling
there's a lot that we can do I think
that that one of the things that we
should not do is rely on organizations
like the American Civil Liberties Union
or the national event the n-double-a-cp
we cannot rely on them to fight our
battles when we are victims of racial
profiling we really have to do it
ourselves we have to take proactive
steps even if it's just a matter of
writing a complaint letter or sending in
a formal complaint letter against the
officer who violated our rights or
racially profilers sometimes that's
enough because then in his personnel
file there is a legal document that says
this guy engaged in racial profiling
sometimes that's all it takes you know
that way in the future if something
happens and they go in this file and
they see that yo this kid engaged in
profiling we got him you know sometimes
it's it's something as simple as that
sometimes it's as simple as just a
word-of-mouth campaign you know fast or
racially profiling tell your friends
about it no this game profoundly I'm not
kidding you I'm not giving them my
dollar you know I mean it may not put
them out of business but at least you're
taking proactive steps I think that I
think that we need to just do things
like that in general
now in general you know I can't I know
Chicago has their own stories of people
being killed by police officers and I
know
all of us have stories so I really
invite you all to to tell me and you
know I'm interested in hearing your
stories as well so please by all means
if you have any questions any any
comments any experiences that you like
to share because sometimes it's just a
matter of getting it off your chest you
know I'm here to listen
and ask you know that's that's it um
that's pretty much pretty much my
presentation with regards to racial
profiling the book itself is basically
I've interviewed various people from the
highways who's been profiled in shopping
centers who were profiled and department
stores are black coming through customs
I've shown how they have empowered
themselves and fought back hoping that
readers when they read this they get
ideas and it's basically that type of a
guidebook so I hope that you guys get a
chance to look through it and enjoy it
and talk about it to other people
because dialogue is really how we're
going to do our we need to let people
know that we know racial profiling
exists we're aware of it and we just
don't take it anymore thank you
yes sir
yeah the first thought I think that
parents have to take proactive steps
that they're gonna take care of their
kids you know like I said parents y'all
if you if you say no if you tell your
kids to say no to drugs in the park to
save sex you can very easily tell them
you know when you're in the police
officer don't argue stay calm keep your
hands in plain sight if you're in a car
turn on the dome light and never ever
reach for anything I think we have to
tell our kids when they're 5 years old
when they're 8 years old when they're 10
12 and as they become teenagers
literally every other day you know
another thing that we could do is
actually sponsor workshops you know
maybe in the school there was a lady
here I was just talking to she's a
teacher she says that she tilts she has
discussed the conversation with her kids
on a regular basis you know I think that
people are in our churches and
synagogues things like that we can
actually have workshops with kids that
are that's required you know um
it could be something as simple as that
you know have workshops where you know
if you racially profile how are you
going to react you know things like that
because like I said this is just a
driving while black is merely a snapshot
of how racial profiling exists today and
what we can do about it but because
racial profiling is huge it's bigger
than me it's because it's so big that
it's gonna take a collective effort from
us as individuals from us as a community
and from us just just as a people yes
with the exception of the u.s. customs
experience have you noticed any
difference in gender and beyond just the
law enforcement but as you mentioned
shopping malls and elsewhere have you
found it more targeted towards black men
than black women or what are the
differences if any most of it most of
the stories that I have come across have
been with men
and young black men I think that with
regards to gender wise it definitely
happens more soda black men than black
women but it happens to black women you
know black women have just as much
trouble sometimes going out at night
China calacatta holla taxi as black men
do you know so and that's why we have to
be particularly pay particular attention
to live like men you know generally you
know there was a story I believe it was
a woman that was killed a year ago here
she was a woman killed you know there
was a lady in California about a year
ago like a year and a half every two
years ago who was shot up in her car she
was sleeping you know that's a woman you
know so I I want to say that for the
most part it's been black men that that
have been the major target that we are
the ones who are being pursued
aggressively by police officers but I
don't want to exclude women too because
it happens to them as well and may I say
for white folks if you have kids with
long hair who sort of been gulfs and
incorporates hip-hop gear in the hip-hop
environment they get profiled - there
was a white woman who talked who came up
to me about I guess about three weeks
ago we were talking about racial
profiling she said her 17 year old son
was racially profiling because he's got
this long hair he wears body clothes he
hangs out with black folks you know it's
this kind of his hairstyle and he was
profiled and they - you know so it
crosses gender because you know if it
affects us all because if law
enforcement is going to just protect one
part of society and not another part of
society come on you know you know what
that's gonna go you know when is it you
know it's it basically affects us all
probable cause never something else
before probable cause so if an officer
just stops you and let's say I have
nothing in my car
nothing so there is no probable cause
that he wants to search you recommend to
do what that's reasonable suspicion
that's all he's got his reasonable
suspicion if he says excuse me sir I
like to say I'd like you to step out of
your car so that I could search it I
mean if he asked you to step by the car
you have to step out of the car but if
he says I want to search your car if
there's only reasonable suspicion then
your first reaction would be well first
I want to see the consent to search form
all offices and and one of the things
that that every state has their own
individual laws and in general and I
have to preface all of this I am NOT an
attorney I did not go to law school this
is just based on my research and from
talking to attorneys himself that
generally across the country when an
officer only has reasonable suspicion
and they want to search a car they must
present to you a consent to search form
in which I recommend you read it because
in it it says you have the right to say
no so with that you simply say I like to
exercise my right against unreasonable
searches and seizures I do not want my
car searched in that case they will say
fine we're gonna call in the dogs so
they're gonna get that German Shepherds
it may take it may cost you a half hour
out of your day it's an inconvenience
that's the problem with racial profiling
but just be aware that that is what's
going to happen they will call the dogs
they'll come by and they're sniff your
card every which way inside out or not
inside but every which way but loose
basically and when it's over they will
either issue a ticket or go home they
they are sniffing for a venereal car the
story that I have in here of Robert
Wilkins the the dog actually jumped onto
the hood of the car sniffed in between
where the windshield wipers are jumped
up on the side of the door slipped under
under where they are the petition
between the windows and the door you
know he sniffed everything went up under
the car so sniffing around the tires and
stuff all the way around it was not just
as simple oh well we're all homies
I mean I mean all over you know just we
have to expect that and we have a right
to say no so now if it's probable cause
once again there's evidence you can't do
anything with that
I mean if they want to search YouTube
and yeah you have to submit so yes ma'am
if you agree not to be searched should
you also ask for the police officers
name and badge number and that's
automatic wouldn't one of the things
another bit of information and in the
book that I recommend is as soon as we
have stopped and pulled off and the
officer comes up to you you know it's
best as possible get ID on that person
badge numbers names memorize you know
what the person look like just try to
get an ID now if these in uniform
naturally they have their names written
on you know they have a little nametag
that they have on that on the uniform if
they are DTS you know you have that
right to say excuse me officer what is
your name what is your ID you know I
want to see ID and they have to present
it to you so that's that's automatic now
some people say but what about if it
makes them mad know you've been racially
profiled you know so I believe that that
that you should that should be automatic
but there's another thing that I that I
also recommend that haven't mentioned
yet and that is always carry pencil and
paper with you in your glove compartment
that way as soon as you are released
from custody which is basically what it
is every traffic stop is basically
you're being held in custody once you
are released I recommend you write
everything down everything all the
details where you are time of day what
was said what the officer look like his
name that his general appearance or her
general parents what I said was I speak
I mean everything just write it all down
so that it's documented because you know
as time goes on we started to get the
little bitty details that would make up
a bigger picture should we decide to
file a complaint should we decide to
take the officer to
you know I'm sorry and that's just
another recommendation that I have but
yes just answering just chuggin name and
things like that so
okay what would you recommend if
african-american woman and man are
together an african-american man does
everything again switcher book says
calming down and just kind of going
along and helping the process out and he
gets angry and upset in a defensive with
the police officer which then puts the
african-american woman in some kind of
danger whatever what do you suggest that
a woman do in that kind of situation
much as possible calm the man down
please I mean you know one of the
mistakes that I made when we were in
Georgia I was in a car with my niece and
her husband we were in Georgia and we
got stopped by Georgia State Troopers
and man this was obviously before the
book because my niece was like you can't
do this I think it's unfair I mean she
went off and the whole time was like
please don't stop chill and it just
wouldn't it didn't stop but luckily we
got her to calm down because it was
really dangerous it's a dangerous
situation there is no second chance when
an officer pulls a gun and shoots you
just got no second chance and it's it's
our emotions that get us killed
so if you're in that situation or if you
know a woman that's in that situation
the best things you could tell that that
person is listen just count if I take
five deep breaths and then say what you
gotta say that's just basic psychology
no yes ma'am
for me as a white person a white woman
you know you you recommend trying to you
know witness these behavior so if I'm
driving down the street and I see a
black man being pulled over I mean
should I as we're going only because let
me see if I can put this in the context
a little bit that was a woman who asked
me that question
um the thing about it when she asked me
is that she was in her neighborhood the
kids who were being stopped were people
that she knew peripherally she didn't
know them like my name but she saw them
around and stuff and when she was coming
into her driveway or coming home she saw
it happening and she asked you know
should she have stopped I say yes we
have to be our brothers keepers if you
see somebody like that in your
neighborhood you know definitely because
these are people that you live with
these are people in your community you
know take take take on take proactive
steps in your community it's hard for us
to recommend it would be hard for me to
recommend that in general to you because
we pass police officers stopping by
people in the regular basis if that were
the case if you were to stop every time
a black person got scared okay you don't
go nowhere
you know basically that's it
I I think that you have to use your gut
instinct you have to use some type of
common sense we all do I think that if
we see if we see a police officer you
know and if we see a black motorist
standing up
there's exchange going on there's
dialogue corner and it's not just you
know yes officer how you doing but it's
joke we told you know blah blah you know
and their officer is bah bah bah then I
think we all should just sort of maybe
stop pullover observe what's going on
because now that is an escalated
situation that's not just a simple
now you know exchange of information
routine information it's it's a bit out
of the norm now because now it has
escalated into danger somebody can get
killed there's one guy with a gun is
another guy who is emotional so I think
that even in the situation like that
even I would sort of slow down take note
say now let's just kind of pull over and
just see what happens here you know
because if something goes down I think
that we need to you know we just we need
to just to help out I mean that's all
and that's all I would recommend but not
at all stop every time you see that yeah
you know you just as well camp out on
the highway 95 anyway I thank you all
for coming out I hope you get a chance
to pick up driving while black highways
shopping malls taxi cab to society walks
what to do when you're a victim of
racial profiling more so than picking it
up and reading it I hope that we
continue the dialogue and talk to our
children talk to our brothers talk to
our sisters talk to each other about how
to behave when we are stopped by a cop
one of the things everyone's becoming
also and to welcome anyone would like to
purchase a book have it find at the
front of the room thank you actually put
you actually right here and just move